So Leute, keine Ahnung wie lange das jetzt geht, aber ich muss mal was anderes machen
als im Bett liegen den ganzen Tag, deswegen hab ich gedacht, ich setze mich jetzt einfach
an den Rechner und mach den Stream an, Keckl, mal gucken, mal gucken wie lange das funktioniert
weil wenn mir der Hals noch mehr wehtut oder ich irgendwie die ganze Zeit husten muss oder
irgendwie sowas dann hat das ja keinen Sinn, aber ich hab gedacht mal so eine halbe Stunde
oder so mal irgendwas anderes machen als im Bett liegen ist gar nicht verkehrt und was
soll ich sonst machen, Stream an und gut ist.
Was kann man sonst machen, für 35 Minuten, eine Stunde machen, ja danke, also ich muss
sagen, also angefangen hat das ganze ja so richtig Freitag Nachmittag oder Freitag Mittag
Nachmittag und also ich war Freitag quasi dann mehr oder weniger den ganzen Tag im Bett
Samstag ganzen Tag im Bett, also ich bin immer mal ein bisschen rumgelaufen hier aber so und
heute ganzen Tag im Bett, ja wahrscheinlich, ja so komme ich mir auch vor, Leute ich muss
mal was erzählen, ich glaub es nicht, wenn man Fieber hat, wenn man, also kein Witz
was ich euch jetzt erzähle, wenn man Fieber hat dann und schläft oder versucht zu schlafen
und so vor sich hin ja döst im Bett mit Fieber, dann denkt man ganz merkwürdige Sachen, ja
so das sind nicht Halluzinationen oder so, ich mein da fürs 39 Grad Fieber zu wenig
aber du denkst so ganz ganz merkwürdige, merkwürdige Sachen und wenn du dann auch
vielleicht irgendwelche YouTube Videos geguckt hast oder so, da kommen dann ganz merkwürdige
Sachen, auch zumindest, Lagerede kurzer Sinn, aus irgendwelchen Gründen habe ich mir bestimmt
3-4 Minuten Gedanken gemacht, habe ich mir bestimmt 3-4 Minuten Gedanken gemacht, wie
man einen eigenen C++ Compiler programmieren, weil es total hängen geblieben ist, ich würde
nie im Leben wäre ich in der Lage dazu, geschweige denn, würde ich das wollen, ja aber ich habe
wirklich dargelegen 3-4 Minuten und habe mir über C++ Compiler Gedanken gemacht und da
siehst du mal was 39 Grad Fieber schon ausmachen können, weirdchamp, ja richtig weirdchamp,
ich glaube dazu hat aber auch beigetragen, dass ich die auf dem Handy habe ich die Ankündigung
zu Carbon mir angeguckt, diese Präsentation von der C++ Konferenz wo sie Carbon vorgestellt
haben, wo ich mich ja immer noch frage, was der Sinn von Carbon überhaupt ist, vielleicht
bin ich das dann drauf gekommen und aus irgendwelchen Gründen war YouTube dann der Meinung es muss
mir total viele Nischenprogrammiersprachen empfehlen und ich habe Videos geguckt über
SICK, über V-Lang, über irgend so ein komisches Haskell-Ding, Abkömmling, wo ich mir gedacht
habe Max warum guckst du dir diese Videos überhaupt an, du wirst nie was damit machen,
so es kann sein Leute, dass ich gleich noch eine Pille nehmen muss, ich muss das Ding,
ich habe hier so eine Pillendose mit Ibu drinne und die muss ich unbedingt desinfizieren,
wenn das Ding jemand angreift das reicht um 20.000 Leute mit Corona anzustecken, äh
zu Kobold nicht, richtig krank ja, deswegen ich mach den Stream auch nicht, weil ich denke
da kommt jetzt irgendwie was wahnsinnig spannendes bei raus, ja habe ich ein bisschen, wobei
es nicht wirklich Schluckbeschwerden sind, sondern es tut weh, ja die Masse macht's
ja, du kannst, du solltest dich halt vielleicht nicht mit Ibu vollstopfen, 24 7 für 3 Wochen,
also mir tut der Hals weh, nee so schlimm ist es nicht, es ist auch ein bisschen, bisschen
besser und es wandert vor allem ja, gestern hat's links im Hals weh getan beim Schlucken,
dann mal Mitte beidseitig, jetzt tut's hauptsächlich rechts weh im Hals, also Rasiermesser würde
ich jetzt nicht sagen, so krass ist es nicht, Leute und ich bin doppelt froh, deswegen rede
ich jetzt auch nicht, weil schrei ich jetzt auch nicht so rum oder so, ich bin auch gar
nicht krank geschrieben, ich, ich äh wollte am Freitag zu meinem Hausarzt, mein Hausarzt
ist im Urlaub und da dachte ich mir, ja gut ich kann 3 Tage daheim bleiben ohne Krankmeldung
und warten wir mal ab wie es Montag ist, Montag gehe ich eh nicht arbeiten, ja dann ruf ich
auch Montag jetzt dann bei irgendeinem Vertretungsarzt hier im Ort an, mal gucken wie das läuft,
weil telefonisch krank schreiben geht ja nicht mehr, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass die wollen, dass ich dahingehe mit Corona, das kann ich mir am besten will nicht vorstellen,
es gibt auch noch die Möglichkeit sowas über eine App zu machen, also die App macht das
ja nicht, die App vermittelt dir ja quasi eine Videosprechstunde bei irgendeinem zugelassenen
Krankenkassen zugelassenen Arzt in Deutschland, die gilt ja keine Frage, weiß aber nicht
was da unsere Personalabteilung von hält, wenn ich eine Krankmeldung von einem Arzt
in München hab, ich mein rechtlich gesehen können sie da wahrscheinlich nichts gegen
machen, aber ich hab keinen Bock jetzt noch wenn ich eh krank bin eine längere Diskussion
zu machen, deswegen hab ich mir überlegt ich mach das so, ich ruf mal bei irgendeinem
Vertretungsarzt an am Montag und je nachdem was für große Zeremonie ich da machen muss
weil ganz ehrlich ich komm kaum aus dem Bett raus aktuell, es hat jetzt gereicht nachdem
ich den ganzen Tag gelegen hab mal mich hier vor den Rechner zu setzen und den Stream anzumachen
das heißt nicht, dass ich irgendwie super fit bin geschweige denn ordentlich aus dem
Haus gehen könnte, ganz einfach abgesehen ich seh aus wie der letzte Frankfurter Penner
gerade, ich hab mich jetzt seit, glaub, 3 nach hab ich mich schnell mal gewaschen, hab
mich nur im Bett gelegen und wenn man Fieber hat schwitzt man auch wie Sau, also wenn ich
jetzt raus gehe, das wie gesagt das ist nicht ein Frankfurter Penner von der Optik her sondern
auch von, das kannst du quasi noch auseinander halten, also was ich gemacht habe ist, richtiger
Gamer genau, also was ich gemacht hab ich hab so nen Lidl Schnelltest gemacht, sowas
mit in die Nase schieben, ich werd das nicht machen, also ich ruf dann, wenn die wirklich
wollen dass ich durch die Weltgeschichte fahr dann frag ich den ob es denn nicht reicht
dass ich krank bin, also mir ist egal ob die Corona feststellen oder nicht, ich mein 39
Grad Fieber, Nase laufen, Halsschmerzen sollten doch, ich muss mich ein bisschen mal zurück
halten, wenn ich Schriemer mach geht das immer so mit mir durch, sollten ja eigentlich reichen
als Grundeinkrank zu schreiben, mir doch egal ob ich feststelle ob ich Corona hab oder nicht
geht mir am Arsch vorbei, mir ist scheiß egal ob die Corona Statistik stimmt, ich will
ne Krankmeldung haben, dass das alles in Ordnung hat und sonst wie meine Mitmenschen gehen
mir am Arsch vorbei, so ist es, ist mir wurscht, scheiß drauf ob die Statistik stimmt, obdach
die schreien mich krank, nee ich werd das anders machen, ich hab keinen Bock mich jetzt
grad wenn ich eh schon so im Arsch bin mich mit Leuten rum zu streiten, ich ruf dann
auf der Arbeit an und frag in der Personalabteilung wie das bei uns Regelungen sind, wie das mit
den 3 Tagen ausgelegt wird und ob das im Zweifelsfall auch was tut mit Videosprechstunde und wenn
die sagen ja wovon ich mal auskehe, dann mach ich Videosprechstunde und gut ist, tja so
ist das bei meinem normalen auch, das ist auch der einzige Grund warum ich da noch hingehe,
der einzige Grund warum ich zu dem Arzt gehe, zu dem ich gehe ist, also ich geh zu dem nur
wenn ich weiß ich hab irgendwas wofür ich ne Krankmeldung brauch, ja Erkältung durch
Dünnschiss oder so, nee 1.2 ruf ich an Notfall ruf ich doch deswegen nicht an, sag ich gleich
was zu ich wollt jetzt noch hier was, ja wie gesagt danke Patrick für den Sub deswegen
geh ich auch zu meinem Arzt hier zu meinem Hausarzt, einfach wenn ich irgendwas hab von
Dünnschiss bis Erkältung wo ich weiß ich brauch ne Krankmeldung kannste eh nix machen
geh ich zu dem weil das super unkompliziert ist, den will ich meistens noch nicht mal
richtig sehen, dafür kann er halt auch nix, wenn du wirklich krank bist, war schon ein
paar mal da wo ich wirklich mal das Bedürfnis hatte untersucht zu werden, konntest du halt
auch komplett vergessen, war es mittlerweile so wenn ich wirklich untersucht werden möchte
und das schnell gehen soll und ich da qualitativ meine ordentliche Aussage haben will dann
ruf ich irgendwo an und sag ich bezahl selbst, natürlich kannst du das nicht alles machen
weil manches ist halt mega teuer, ja also dann müsstet ihr dich schon wirklich gleich
privat versichern lassen ja aber selbst dann ist halt in meinem gesundheitszustand fragwürdig
ob sich das lohnt, weil ich bin so gut wie nie krank, ich bin auch so gut wie nie beim
Arzt, also ich würde definitiv aktuell massiv drauf zahlen aber das ist halt so ein bisschen
gamble vielleicht zahlt sich später aus, ja also wie gesagt es ist an sich wenn ich
wirklich still im Bett liege und nix mache dann tut mir nur der Hals weh und man fühlt
sich halt scheiße wegen Nase verstopft und Fieber aber also es ist nicht so als würde
ich sterben aber also irgendwie groß aufstehen und lange rumlaufen oder gar aus dem haus
gehen traue ich mir da nicht zu, ja wie gesagt ich habe jetzt den ganzen Tag rumgelegen und
habe mir gedacht ich kann jetzt nicht wirklich den kompletten Tag im Bett liegen, ich setze
mich jetzt vor den Rechner und ich wusste nicht was ich machen soll wenn ich vor den
Rechner zähle weißt du was ich mache jetzt einfach den Stream an und wie gesagt ich
glaube nicht dass da halt irgendwie was super tolles rauskommt einfach nur dass ich irgendwas
zu tun habe, ich ein bisschen ablegen kann von ich liege im Bett und bin krank
so und um 19.30 Uhr mal gucken falls ich da noch da bin wir können tatsächlich ein paar
Videos gucken da muss ich nicht so viel labern muss ich mir noch eine Ibu 300 reinhauen,
dass mir der Kopf nicht mehr so weh tut, dass mir der Hals nicht mehr so weh tut, dass vielleicht
die Fieber ein bisschen runter geht dann gehe ich dann 20 Uhr oder so wieder ins Bett
es kommt glaube ich ein bisschen drauf an also ich kenne mich da nicht gut aus aber
ich glaube es kommt ein bisschen drauf an was du für einen Vertrag abschließt es gibt
ja auch Verträge da wird es im Alter nicht teurer dafür bezahlst du von Anfang an mehr
ein also im Durchschnitt wird es das gleiche sein, Premium Hustensirup Schleimlöser Reizlöser
nice das brauche ich auch das Konzert war gut leider war der Sound nicht so geil aber
die Band war gut und die Show war auch pock aber der Sound war halt richtig kacke ja lass
uns ein paar Videos gucken Leute ach haben wir doch letztens schon jede Menge geguckt
ja nä ich frage den dann morgen mal wenn ich da hingehe es soll mir irgendwas aufschreiben
falls es was sinnvolles gibt wpf willst du wirklich wpf verwenden im jahr 2022 also
was ist der grund warum du wpf verwenden willst iron maiden in frankfurt letzte woche
dienstag oder wie die deutschen alle sagen iron maiden mit power wolf als vorgruppe also
noch ein bisschen christlicher power metal dabei gewesen ja klar mache ich noch ich hab
doch schon ein paar gemacht das lässt sich davon ausgehen dass ich ab jetzt keine mehr
mache also nein mich hat keiner verklagt oder so haben sich sogar ein paar gemeldet haben
gesagt sie fanden das cool ein paar haben gesagt sie werden es weitergeben oder sowas
in der richtung paar waren auch nicht so glücklich drüber glaube ich
wollte es eine desktop app entwickeln wenn du windows only machen willst und es wirklich
eine desktop app sein muss dann ist wpf auf jeden fall eine möglichkeit uwp würde ich
jetzt gar nicht anfangen windows forms je nachdem was du machen willst wpf ist schon
ok aber das problem bei wpf ist also problem warum ich wpf nicht so mag ist erstens bin
ich kein fan von xml in die art und weise wie sie da eher ui definieren jetzt kommt
mir nicht an und sagt html ist auch xml ja ich weiß aber xml ist eine runde ekliger
wie html finde ich und das ist halt im prinzip genauso alter shit ist wie windows forms nur
ein bisschen neuer aber nicht neu genug um neue sachen wirklich gut zu unterstützen also
die sinnvollste sache wird tatsächlich winui zu verwenden winui 3 für deine desktop app
das ist das das ist das wie sagt man so schön ab entkommen oder so desktop framework für
windows das ist die technologie aus uwp nur für auch nicht uwp apps die sache ist bloß
die microsoft also version 3 muss du nehmen nicht version 2 version 3 ist das was sache
ist die preview version die sache ist die microsoft kommt nicht zu pötte mit ihrem
scheiß das heißt eigentlich gibt es aktuell keine gute möglichkeit native windows app
apps mit microsoft technologien zu entwickeln das beste was du machen kannst so blöd klingt
ist sowas wie elektron wenn du es einfach haben willst und du keine wirklich in die
tiefgreifende native windows integration brauchst oder kannst du auch mal aphalonia
ausprobieren da hast du da hast du die möglichkeit aphalonia ist quasi cross platform wpf oder
sagen also es ist nicht cross platform wpf es ist eine ein cross platform ui framework
für dort net inspiriert von wpf und uwp wahrscheinlich würde ich mir das hier als
erstes angucken dann hast du immerhin die option das ganze auch cross platform zu machen
falls du das willst und wahrscheinlich ist es für windows only auch besser als so legacy
krempel wie wpf keine ahnung jetzt muss ich erstmal korona abhaken ja gut kannst theoretisch
eine web anwendung machen mit elektron und aber das ist das dann das also das ist schon
ein bisschen eklig dann für desktop anwendung ich meine man könnte ganz abgedrehten shit
machen elektron mit web assembly hast du den browser auf dem desktop mit desktop zeug
in browser als desktop anwendung aber ich glaube nicht dass man das wirklich ernsthaft
machen sollte ne maui ist müll meiner meiner meiner persönlichen meinung nachher ja immernoch
kann ich machen wenn du willst kann ich das nachgucken aber was ist hier los warum sind
meine eigenes broken guck mal meine eigenes meine eigenes sind kaputt keckel was ist da
erstmal starten desktop zu voll quatsch der desktop ist genau richtig scheinlich habe
ich das nicht an wenn das irgendwelche grafikkartenfunktionen braucht so blöds klingt java ist wahrscheinlich
gar nicht swing vielleicht nicht sondern wie heißt das neue leute nicht swing java fx
ist das neue das soll gar nicht mal so kacke sein ok also was soll ich gucken chrome gpu
3 slashe machen moment das ist firefox kein wunder dass das nicht geht das kann man doch
bestimmt auch bei firefox gucken oder ok was soll ich gucken was soll ich gucken
wie geht das bei firefox about flex oder so ne about doppelpunkt flex
fingerprint leak oh nein was wolltest du wissen das da das ist
eh rast das da willst du wissen ok nice about konfig ist es in about konf konfig ist es
in about gpu ah er baut support ist was anderes ach keine ahnung ist auch wurscht ah man nutz
klimaanlage anmachen ist zu warm könnte 39 grad fieber liegen kacke weight yes this voice
line ok was gucken wir dann this gamer just did the impossible in super mario 64 ah ist
es der der das der 120 sterne mit mit augenbinde gemacht hat das habe ich live geguckt vor
zwei drei monaten das ging irgendwie frage ich elf stunden oder so oder länger der run
auf seinem channel geht glaube ich elf und halb stunden das ist richtig krass ich habe
es teilweise live geguckt auf twitch natürlich nicht elf stunden am stück richtig richtig
krass vielleicht sieht man mich sogar manchmal im chat falls die chat sachen haben ich weiß
ob irgendwas gepostet hat doch ich glaube schon glaube ich habe sogar hello hello youtube
gepostet am ende so sack schauen wir uns das doch mal an absolut legend das intro von dem
trigger mich irgendwie immer ein bisschen ich weiß nicht warum es hört sich immer
so so resident sleeper all we have officially die videos die videos trotzdem immer recht
gut also da sieht man mal intro mein intro ist auch kacke intros haben nichts zu sagen
leider ist es für youtube unglaublich wichtig und bei ihm klappt das übrigens meine letzten
videos leute muss ich mal sagen ist heute nicht geburtstag ja da sagste was ja leute
ich bin auf heute 38 und sitzt mit corona hier falsches emote sehr gerät wollte ich
gar nicht einblenden ich wollte eigentlich den old champ einblenden fields birthday man
ja wir haben das emote sogar drin für einen tag im jahr die letzten videos kamen alle
ziemlich gut an moin das ist ja ewig her ich kann mich noch dunkel dran erinnern du hast
ja einen schlechten tag ausgesucht ich sitze mit corona vom rechner was für ein geburtstag
38 wo frau und kind channel wenn ich frau und kind hätte dann würde ich wahrscheinlich
nicht jetzt hier vom rechner sitzen und streamen wahrscheinlich würde ich sonst auch nicht
vom rechner sitzen und fünf stunden streamen also ich muss sagen ich bin relativ also ich
hatte noch nie eine so nervige ich nenne es jetzt mal erkältung weil ich habe nur erkältung
symptome ja ich habe eine halsschmerzen ich habe fieber ich habe halsweben nase laufen
aber also ich habe weder atemprobleme noch sterbe ich gleich also volle dank für den
zapp also wenn das milder verlauf ist dann will ich echt nicht wissen was schwerer verlauf
ist der sebaro hatte geburtstag wahnsinn cute mod himself der müsste sich auch mal wieder
blicken lassen noch nicht ja also ich würde sagen dass es prinzipiell heute schon einen
minimal tick besser ist als gestern vielleicht bin ich mir das auch ein
ihr face reveal stimmt dann sieht da sieht man mich tatsächlich
irgendwo in dem video irgendwo hier sieht man mich wirklich relativ gut ja da sitzt
er guckt euch an da sitzt er von wann ist das ja noch 15 kilo schwerer
nee da ist nicht viel zu sehen
es stimmt das habe ich ganz vergessen ja habe ich auch mir tun meine beine weh so am
gelenken ja ganz komisch und und auch am elbogen und so ja das habe ich ganz vergessen ja das
habe ich auch
ich glaube ich werde schon überleben so gucken wir uns das video mann ich nicht so viel labern
muss
ich habe schon öfters bei ihm mal in seine blind fold in franz reingeguckt
und erzählt immer zwischendurch auf deutsch 1 2 3 das zählt irgendwie die takte der musik
wann er wie springen muss also richtig abgedreht das blind fold zu machen und die zählt er
auf deutsch deswegen würde ich vermuten dass es ein deutscher ist
ich auch nicht vor allem was soll ich mal überlegen elf stunden fuck oder elf stunden
nee da trollt nicht das glaube ich bei ihm nicht weil der macht das ja schon jahre lang
blind folded content und der also würde der würde schon ganz schöne strecken gehen das
zu faken und wenn es rauskommt könnte halt auch einpacken ne ne das ist schon da bin
ich mir sehr sicher das ist legit
das bekommt man homosystem wie auf dem m1 zum laufen ja würde schon sagen müsste gehen
die regelungen bei uns in deutschland sind teilweise echt bescheuert ich habe gesehen
in österreich in österreich ist ab 1.8 wieder krank schreiben per telefon möglich
er erinnert sich noch jemand als er rainbow roach gespielt hat und gucken konnte gerade
wenn das euer erstes 3d mario war was es ja es war das erste 3d mario also für uns damals
war es definitiv das erste 3d mario und wahrscheinlich sogar das erste richtige 3d platform
game und wie schwierig wir uns getan haben mit rainbow road wo wir was gesehen haben
es ist mir doch egal ob es quarantäne gibt es gibt eine krankmeldung das ist mir doch
egal
ach so du meinst jetzt in österreich ja ja
der war wahrscheinlich fertig nach 11 stunden
f r
Ich hoffe wirklich, dass ihr es genieße.
Jetzt, Legende, bevor wir weitergehen, musste ich euch diesen tollen neuen Wissenschaftler zeigen...
...einen großen Studium, der vorhin geliefert wurde.
Es zeigte sich, dass die Menschen 69% mehr attraktiv waren als mögliche Partner, wenn sie...
...sensitiven Bereichen, getrimmt, zertifiziert und gut umgedreht.
Denkt daran! Würdest du eher eine Deskription?
Du bekommst 20% ab und gratis Schiff.
Also klick den Link und fang dich an bei Lawn Mower.
Wenn du mich vor einem Nintendo 64 befestigt hättest...
...dann würde ich gar keine Ahnung, wo zu Beginn starten.
Aber wie es so ist, mit vielen dieser verrückten Gaming Features...
...wurde es mit relativ hohen Beginnungen begonnen und wurde von dort aus.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass das nicht immer der Fall ist, aber generell werden die Spieler...
...können und sagen, ja, 120 Sterne, auf geht's.
Das ist genau das, was mit Super Mario 64 passiert ist.
Der Speedrunner Bubzia war inspiriert von anderen Schaffungen, wie in...
...Legend der Zelda, und hat sich entschieden, ob er am wenigsten eine einzelne Star...
...blindfolden könnte. Und im Juli 2017 hat er genau das getan.
Von hier aus hat er nur noch ein paar Sterne ausgeführt, bis er ein total von 16 hat.
Das ist ein wichtiges Zeichen, weil 16 Sterne generell die einfachste Art...
...der Spiel zu gewinnen sind. Technisch kann man das Spiel mit 0 oder 1 Sterne gewinnen...
...aber es wird schwieriger, weil man das Glitch machen muss.
Das ist extrem präzise. Die Glitche, die man für einen 16-Star-Run braucht, sind ziemlich einfach.
Nach einigen Monaten Arbeit im Oktober 2017 wurde Bubzia die erste Person, die Super Mario 64...
...blindfolden konnte. Dieser 16-Star-Run hat 3,5 Stunden gedauert und, überraschend, hat es nicht...
...eine ganze Menge Aufmerksamkeit online bekommen. Ich hätte gedacht, dass es...
...eine große Nachricht wäre, aber niemand hat wirklich darüber gesprochen...
...und diese erste Runde hat nur noch 600 Stunden.
Es macht mir einfach keinen Spaß mehr zu gucken, dass es so durchgeplant und poliert mittlerweile...
...und es wird an jeder Ecke darauf geachtet, dass auch keiner nur ein falsches Wort sagt...
...und dass es dann auch nicht falsch... Irgendwie hast du das Gefühl, gerade bei...
...Gamestone Quick hast du das Gefühl, die Leute um Schiffen alles getriggert sein...
...um 5 Kilometer im Voraus schon. Was es dann irgendwie auch ultra durchkalkuliert...
...und langweilig macht. Ja, professionell könnte man vielleicht sagen, ja.
Deswegen irgendwie habe ich keinen Spaß mehr. Schön, wer es mag, soll es ja ruhig gucken...
...aber ich habe keinen Spaß mehr großartig an Gamestone Quick gucken.
ESA fand ich cool. Dieses Jahr lief ja bis Samstag.
Und kleinere Events gucke ich mir auch ganz gerne an, aber Gamestone Quick gefällt mir nicht mehr.
Naja, überlegt euch mal. Der 120-Sterne-Run hat 11 Stunden gedauert. 11,5 Stunden.
Das ist schon heftig, oder? Belegt mal, wie viel Übung und Hartnäckigkeit, so wie sagt man...
...so Dedication, wie nennt man das auf Deutsch? Ich kann nicht denken, heute Leute...
...so Hingebung oder so. Das braucht, so hartnäckig trifft es eigentlich, Hingabe, genau.
Wie viel Hingabe und wie hartnäckig man da sein muss, um das durchzukreiselgrinden...
...bis man das drauf hat. Man muss auf jeden Fall leidensfähig sein.
Und das glaubst du denen auch nicht, weil das war das Fake-Laser-Licht bestimmt. Bestimmt fake.
Also ich würde das nur glauben, wenn du dir danach zum Beweis da auch reinguckst.
Und mir dann bestätigt, dass es echt funktioniert.
Auch schon krass, oder? Nobori ist auch krass, was das angeht. Von dem habe ich aber schon...
...ein paar Runs gesehen. Mir geht es ganz okay in den Umständen.
Okay, in den Umständen entsprechend, ja. Nicht wirklich gut, aber okay.
Solange ich einfach nur vorm Rechner sitzen muss, so irgendwie auf halb acht hängen...
...und nichts machen, ist in Ordnung. Nö, ich habe keinen Test gemacht, wo denn?
Es ist Wochenende. Patrick, das ist eine geile Vorstellung. Das trifft es wahrscheinlich.
Zu geil. Wahrscheinlich ist das ungefähr realistisch, ja. Die zehn Prozent der Verbindungen...
...in seinem Hirn sind nur noch vorhanden, dass er das Spiel spielen kann.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist es so.
Aber krass, eine Stunde 26 oder für 70 Sterne, 70 Sterne, es ist schon heftig.
Geht mir auch so, Patrick. Ich weiß nicht, ob du da schon da warst. Ich habe den Fehler gemacht.
Ich habe den Carbon Talk gehört auf dem Handy, als ich mit Fieber im Bett gelegen habe.
Und danach habe ich mir immer C++-Compiler-Gedanken gemacht, so mit 39 Grad Fieber...
...bei einem vor mich hin dösen. Leute, man denkt an übelsten Schwachsinn nach, sage ich euch.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja ein paar Mal die Runs geguckt von dem jetzigen Rekordhalter da...
...und der hat schon krasse Strats drauf. Man sieht es ja teilweise, gerade in diesem Lava-Land-Level...
...da gibt es ja diese Augen, um die man kreisen muss, dass du die blauen Münzen kriegst.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr die kennt. Da gibt es ja diese Augen, da muss man drumherum rennen...
...und dann drehen die sich so und da kommen blaue Münzen raus. Und das muss der so time...
...dass er danach weiß, worauf er steht, dass es übel Sticks hat.
Die Musik kann sehr hilfreich sein, denn sie kann dich in eine bestimmte Richtung...
...für die gleiche Menge Zeit bewegen, wenn du wirklich gut auf den Beat zählst.
In der Praxis, bewegen die gleiche Distanz und die Richtung jedes Mal...
...kann oft recht einfach sein. Im Endeffekt werden die Spieler so konsistent...
...dass sie es eigentlich auf Befehl machen können. Im Dezember 2021...
...bezog Bubzia das Spiel mit 70 Stars live während eines Marathons in 1 Stunde und 55 Minuten.
Natürlich, mit den 70 Stars jetzt ziemlich niedrig, wurde die Frage, ob die Spieler...
...die ganze Distanz bewegen können. Könnte es möglich sein, jede Star in dem Spiel zu holen?
Im Januar 2021 setzte C'Thun diese Frage an. Und über die nächsten paar Monate...
...wurde er systematisch durch die restlichen Stars gehen, um zu sehen, ob es möglich war...
...das zu machen. Nach dem letzten März hatte er erfolgreich herausgefunden...
...dass C'Thun die ganze Distanz bewegen konnte. Im Dezember 2021 setzte C'Thun...
...die ganze Distanz bewegen konnte. Und über die nächsten paar Monate...
...wurde er systematisch durch die restlichen Stars gehen, um zu sehen, ob es möglich war...
...das zu machen. Nach dem letzten März hatte er erfolgreich herausgefunden...
...dass C'Thun die ganze Distanz bewegen konnte. Nach dem letzten März hatte er erfolgreich...
...dass C'Thun die ganze Distanz bewegen konnte. Und zwar durch die restlichen Stars.
sagen
persönlich im antrieb und ich frage mich immer
wurde also
wieder zustande kommt
Ob es einfach nur das ist dass die dass die noch das letzte rausholen wollen uns für die halt einfach die übelste motivation ist
wenn sie wieder zwei sekunden schneller sind ob es die übelste
klugshormonausschüttung ist wenn du doch wieder mal was bekommst ich
also
ich finde es wirklich bewundernswert so ist so eine
durchhalte durchhalte verbeugung leidensfähigkeit zu haben in dem game
118 just too shy of the 120
but it was here that katun ultimately ended his journey as he couldn't figure out how to collect the final two the two remaining
stars were the 100 coin stars on the levels lethal lava land and dire dire docks and it's these two levels that perfectly
illustrate the difference between 70 star and
120 star with 70 stars the biggest weapon you have in your arsenal is choice
You get to choose which stars you collect and which stars you skip
Aber wenn du alle sammeln willst ist vorbei
blindfolded beyond 70 stars get exponentially more difficult a level like whomp's fortress is easy to navigate
Wenn die sich übrigens in solchen speed runs treffen lassen ist es oftmals gar nicht so sehr ein fehler sondern es ist oftmals sogar absicht
um zu wissen wo man ist
The time moving around as long as you know the right combination of inputs
It doesn't really matter if you do them slowly or quickly as long as you do them in the correct order
You'll be successful
There aren't too many enemies to avoid and there are also plenty of opportunities to do a technique that blindfolded runners call
Normalization normalization is where I play can use the terrain to know exactly where they are
It could be as simple as just listening for when mario is pushing up against a wall by the way
Ich vermute mal das hier war war ein versuch
Hier kann man ja wenn man lang springt den stern aus der wand holen und ich gehe davon aus der probiert das und wenn das nicht
Funktioniert macht er mit dem anderen weiter
Wie man so schön sagt back up strat
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal
Mario ist pushing up against a wall a player could also slowly walk off a ledge and allow mario to grabe kennen das genau das meine ich
The player now knows exactly where they are standing and can proceed from there
Normalization is important because it allows you to break stars into smaller sections
So you don't need to do the entire thing perfectly you just need to make it to the next checkpoint where you can normalize your position
On a level like lethal avalanche da ist er halb verzweifelt wie gesagt ich war ja ich hatte das glück dass ich
Zwischenzeitlich live geguckt habe bei ihm wo er den rekord aufgestellt hat
Da ist er oder ich habe auch den tag ich habe auch die tage vorher schon geguckt und an einem tag ist er hier wirklich komplett
verzweifelt drin gerade hier auch in dieser ecke
Ich ihn ist oft ein impossible
Plattform data hat irgendwie glaube ich allein schon eine stunde nur für dieses level gebraucht
Hier unser zukunftsart er war
Es und da geht's auf besser
Been
Hier Liesel Loverland, er fängt an bei 1.20
Und geht und hier lief alles gut bis 1.56
Also hat 40 Minuten gebraucht
45, nee, was, quickmuffs, Leute
Hier war immer von 1.20
Also ja, 1.35
So und da lief alles gut
Tag wo ich geguckt hab, ist er nach einer Stunde halb verzweifelt da dran
Kommt mal und für
Äh, für das Sandlevel hat er von 4.2 zu 5.40 gebraucht
Eine Stunde 30 für ein Level
Krass oder?
Da nicht abzubrechen
Oh, ja
Ja, das sind die mit dem Strudel
Leute, nach dem Video gehe ich auf, mir läuft die Nase und mein Hals tut weh, ich lege mich dann wieder hin
Aber das gucken wir noch fertig
Jo, Dankeschön
Oh, das, das, das hab ich, das hab ich live zugeguckt, wie er, wie er das, ähm, dieses, dieses, dieses Sprungrätsel hier gemacht hat, das ist wirklich krass, also
Ich hab ein Stück
Jo
In Ordnung, um alle Red-Coin blind zu füllen, braucht man viele perfekte Inputs zurückzulegen.
Auch für einen Spieler wie Bubzia, mit dem er praktizieren kann, muss man sich mal vorstellen,
du hast keine Möglichkeit hier irgendwie festzustellen, wo du bist.
Das geht rein über Timing und Movement, weil du kennst ja eigentlich so wirklich bloß deine Startposition.
Du kannst auch nicht mal nebenbei gegen eine Wand laufen und checken, wo du bist.
Du fliegst einfach in der Luft.
Also das stelle ich mir unglaublich schwer vor.
Go, Liko, danke.
Eine Stunde und 15 Minuten für ein Stern.
Das ist halt wirklich heftig.
Am 18. März 2022 würde Bubzia seinen ersten Versuch machen.
Seine Erzählung, wie lange die Runde dauern würde, war 15 Stunden.
Das ist ein sehr langer Zeitpunkt, um ein Spiel blind zu spielen.
Es ist nicht das längste, das jemand gemacht hat, aber es ist immer noch ein extrem langer Zeitpunkt.
Blind zu spielen, ist extrem mental anstrengend, sogar mehrso als regelmäßig Speedrunning.
In meiner Erfahrung in Speedrunning, nach einer bestimmten Menge Praxis,
entwickelst du Muskelmemory und kannst eigentlich auf Autopilot spielen.
Das ist nicht der Fall mit blind zu spielen, aber Konzentration ist nötig.
In Speedrunning, nach einer bestimmten Menge Praxis,
entwickelst du Muskelmemory und kannst eigentlich auf Autopilot spielen.
Das ist nicht der Fall mit blind zu spielen, aber Konzentration ist nötig.
Spieler versuchen immer, Inputs zu erinnern.
Und weil das Spiel viel schneller spielt als sonst, macht das alles viel mehr bewegend.
Nach einem langen Zeitpunkt, werden Spieler zerstört, ähnlich wie ein Chessspieler.
In einem sehr anstrengenden Spiel war es zu viel.
Nach einem langen Zeitpunkt, werden Spieler zerstört,
ähnlich wie ein Chessspieler.
In einem anstrengenden Spiel war es zu viel.
Nach einem langen Zeitpunkt, werden Spieler zerstört,
ähnlich wie ein Chessspieler.
Wenn das passiert ist, was soll man tun?
Wenn man nicht sieht und nicht weiß, wie viele Knöpfe zu drücken sind, ist es nicht möglich, weiter zu gehen.
Nach 40 Minuten ein anstrengendes Fr Schmuck die B wh 2 Internet Sri,
aus 1.5 Stunden Olivia korrigiere sich durch die Welt nach zehnten, die
Im Laufe der Erfehlungen hat Bubzia einen weiteren Monat für seinen nächsten Versuch gebraucht,
welches am 8. Mai sein würde.
Dieses Mal hat er viel besser gespielt und es hat gezeigt.
Alles hat sich wirklich gut gemacht und nach 11 Stunden hatte er 119 Stars.
Er hat die schwerste Star als Letztes verlassen.
Die Windcap-Stage hat 8 Red-Coin-Stars.
Normalerweise würde diese Star mindestens eine Stunde an Versuchungen dauern.
Aber dieses Mal hat es in weniger als 20 Minuten gemacht.
Manchmal braucht man auch einfach neben Skill ein bisschen Glück.
Wie sagt man da so? Redewendung?
Ist das das Glück der Durchsticken oder so?
Was sagt man da?
Also ab und zu kann auch mal nicht Aaron Jesus gegen dich sein.
Ich meine, könnt ihr euch vorstellen, wie schwierig es für uns war schon überhaupt zu treffen während man was sieht?
Nice, krasser Scheiße.
Das ist schon heftig.
Ja, ohne die Katze hätte das definitiv nicht funktioniert, das kenne ich.
Ok Leute, ich habe es länger durchgehalten als ich gedacht habe.
Ich lege mich jetzt wieder hin.
Vielleicht ist morgen doch noch mal eine Ecke besser.
Alles klar, wir sehen uns bis dann.
Tschüss, ciao.